They say our people
were born on the water.
The very first enslaved
Africans were brought
here over 400 years ago.
Since then, no part
of America's story
has been untouched by
the legacy of slavery.
This is The 1619 Project.
The New York Times.
1619 project.
It is the legacy of slavery.
My father, he always flew
a flag in our front yard.
One thing about
dad, he was patriotic.
He was a part of
the United States Army.
They served their country.
But hey, you served country
don't mean your country
going to serve you.
The truth is Black Americans
have always been foundational
to the idea of American freedom.
Democracy is a fight.
It will always be a fight.
Stand and fight.
You are calling
for reparations.
What is the total
that would be owed?
$14 trillion.
- That's a big number.
- Yeah.
Big debt, though.
It is a big debt.
We are still fighting.
As long as there's life,
we're going to have hope.
When I hear Funk,
I hear freedom.
There are centuries
in that music.
Centuries in that spirit.
The 1619 Project,
it's not a history.
It really is talking
about America today.
Black Americans
contributions are undeniable.
No people had a greater claim
to the American flag than we do.